in the White House where President Trump
played through on the North Lawn this
morning the president using some pretty
pointed language to keep up his attack
on some current and former members of
the FBI following the release of the
Inspector General report on the Clinton
email investigation that was part of a
wide-ranging off-the-cuff interview here
on Fox this morning
correspondent Kevin course is at the
White House tonight to show us good even
Kevin good evening my friend the
president's penchant for the
unpredictable shall we say taken to a
whole new level this morning Brett as he
engaged journalists in a pretty spirited
conversation right here on the North
Lawn and then quickly made news that
traveled around the globe you go into
the FBI and take a poll of the real FBI
not the scum on top not call me in that
group of people that total things it was
as freewheeling and bombastic as it was
remarkable President Trump today held an
impromptu news conference on the White
House North Lawn following a lengthy
exclusive interview with Fox & Friends
while the conversation covered a wide
range of topics from North Korea to the
economy mr. Trump zeroed in on
yesterday's release of the bombshell
Inspector General report on the Clinton
email investigation I think that the
report yesterday maybe more importantly
than anything it totally exonerates me
there was no collusion
there was no obstruction and if you read
the report you'll see that while the
report did not exonerate the president
it did criticize former FBI director Jim
Comey saying he'd been insubordinate
during the probe and deviated from
well-established department policies I
think that James Comey was unfair to the
people of this country I think what he
did was a disgrace I think he goes down
as the worst FBI director in history by
far the president also vented about the
one-time lead investigator of both the
Clinton and Russia inquiries Peter
struck the discredited FBI agent whose
behavior the Inspector General concluded
was biased and antithetical to the core
values of the FBI and DOJ Peter struck
should have been fired a long time ago
and others later almost in passing the
president made what amounted to a major
announcement about the u.s. s largest
trading partner China were putting
tariffs on fifty billion dollars worth
of Technology
and other things because we have to
because we've been treated very unfairly
the Trump administration hit Beijing
with a steep 25% tariff on 50 billion
dollars in goods retaliation said the
president for unfair trade practices
that drew the support of New York
Democratic Senator Chuck Schumer who
called the president's actions on China
on the money calling them our real trade
enemy Beijing vowed to fight back if the
u.s. takes unilateral and protectionist
measures that harm China's interests we
will immediately respond and take
necessary measures to defend our
legitimate rights and interests also
getting the president's attention today
although perhaps unwanted attention was
his EPA administrators got through it
the subject of numerous ongoing
investigations and controversies
including a report in today's Washington
Post that an energy PR executive helped
him score Rose Bowl tickets I'm looking
at Scott and Scott's done a fantastic
job at EPA but I'm not happy about
certain things I'll be honest the
embattled EPA chief under fire for
allegedly wasting taxpayer money and
violating ESSEC standards as well as
asking some government employees Brett
to run personal errands but at this
point he still has the support of the
President himself Brett Kevin Corrigan
live in the North Lawn Kevin thanks